depuis son adoption par les députés le
projet de loi sécurité globale a fait un
passage en commission des lois au sénat
le 3 mars dernier
73 amendements ont été adoptés et
l'article 24 celui qui cristallisait
notamment les tensions a été réécrit des
modifications apportées au texte initial
donc afin de protéger à la fois les
forces de l'ordre et la liberté de la
presse selon les mots des sénateurs nous
l'avons profondément cadrés pour que le
continuum de sécurité sur lequel nous
sommes d'accord puisse exercer dans les
meilleures conditions possibles à savoir
à la fois une efficacité pour nos
services de police et de sécurité et en
même temps une protection des libertés
initialement voici ce que prévoyait le
fameux article 24 un an d'emprisonnement
et 45000 euros d'amendé pour toute
diffusion dans le but qu'il soit porté
atteinte à son intégrité physique ou
psychique l'image du visage ou tout
autre élément d'identification d'un
fonctionnaire de la police nationale ou
d'un militaire de la gendarmerie
nationale lorsqu'il agit dans le cadre
d'une opération pour ses détracteurs
cette article 24 est purement et
simplement une atteinte aux libertés de
la presse
les sénateurs eux souhaitent donc tirer
totalement un trait dessus et le
remplacer par un nouveau délit celui de
provocation à l'identification d'un
policier d'un gendarme ou d'un policier
municipal ou d'un membre de leur famille
il intègre aussi l'interdiction de créer
des fichiers à des fins d'identification
malveillante des agents publics
du côté des autres articles les
sénateurs souhaitent cadres et leurs
applications pour les drones par exemple
il met en évidence la nécessité de
réserver leur usage à certaines
circonstances où ils sont
particulièrement adaptés comme des lieux
difficiles d'accès autre exemple dans
l'article 21 la commission a retiré la
disposition qui prévoyait la diffusion
par le ministère de l'intérieur des
images des caméras piétons des policiers
pour l'information du public
mais cette copie corrigée par le sénat
est loin de satisfaire les opposants au
texte qui voit le glissement d'un état
de droit vers un état policier
l'ensemble de la loi élargit de manière
indiscriminée les pouvoirs de
surveillance de la police en
généralisant lusage des drones et de
caméras piétons dispositif pouvant être
relié à des logiciels de reconnaissance
faciale qui annihile
toute notion de vie privée dans l'espace
public ce texte avec le projet de loi
comportant les principes de la
république
les décret élargissant le fichage
politique où les récentes attaques
contre la liberté académique est le
symbole d'une évolution d'un état de
droit vers un état de police dans lequel
le citoyen est considérée comme une
menace
les appels à la mobilisation ont donc
repris des rassemblements sont prévus à
partir du 13 mars
point d'orgue le 16 jours de l'arrivée
du texte en séance plénière au sénat